hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast a keynote presentation what's
new in the news with prostate cancer
2015 I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits if you want
to obtain the credits please click on
the get your free cm ECE credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to the continuing
education page where you can select a
speaker click on the CEC any button and
it will take you through the process to
obtain your certification this webcast
is designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many as we can and we'll follow up if
we don't have time today you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker jug wml md is
the james h siemens professor of surgery
division of urologic surgery and
director of the Duke prostate Center
Duke Cancer Institute at duke university
medical center prior to joining Duke he
was a professor of surgery at the
uniformed services University of the
Health Sciences in Bethesda Maryland and
an attending neurologic oncologist at
the Walter Reed Army Medical Center in
Washington DC in addition he was
director of the Center for prostate
disease research our Congress mandated
research program of the Department of
Defense in 2004 he completed a 26 year
US Army career retiring as a full
colonel
medical course and became chief of the
division of urologic surgery at Duke
serving is chief from two thousand four
to twenty eleven he brought innovation
and growth to the program most notably
he started the Duke prostate Center
expanded the neurology residency
training program through a novel
collaboration with the Department of
Defense and was able to maintain Duke
urology as a top ten program in the
nation throughout his tenure to learn
more about dr. Mel click on the still
image in the right corner for more
information or go to the website I will
now turn it over to dr. Mel for his
presentation thank you very much it's so
really a pleasure and honor to to be
with you this morning and lab roots is
put together a really nice cancer
program today on on various asset
aspects of prostate cancer and a number
of my friends and research associates
and clinical associates are part of the
program today so again welcome and i'm
going to do a little bit of an overview
kind of a smorgasbord on some of the
things that are hot and in the news with
prostate cancer and i'd like to bring
greetings to everyone tuning in this
morning I know it's fairly early on the
west coast but we appreciate people
logging in and joining us so I bring
greetings from the do prostate center in
Duke University here in Durham North
Carolina and what we're going to cover
today is three issues we're going to
spend some time on the screening debate
it's a really hot topic we're going to
spend some slides on localized prostate
cancer and then a little bit on advanced
prostate cancer and obviously we're just
going to be able to cover the highlights
and some of the new things that are
going on in prostate cancer the first
with regard to prostate screening with
PSA let's start with an audience polling
question and I just like to gauge the
audience about your opinion about
prostate cancer screening so the first
question do you believe that prostate
cancer is an old man's disease and no
man should generally be screened for
prostate cancer do you generally feel
that all men should consider PSA testing
to determine their risk and future risk
of prostate cancer do you feel that only
men with higher risk factors such as
african-american ethnicity or family
history should generally be screened or
do you feel that men between 55 and 69
years old should consider prostate
cancer screening using PSA so I just
asked those joining us this morning to
pick your most appropriate answer and
what you believe and submit that and
then we'll have the answers here in just
a minute I will say that while we're
waiting for the answers to come in that
the US Preventive Services Task Force is
against PSA screening and we'll talk
about that in a minute however we're
going to talk about the American
Urological association's best practice
guideline so let's see if we can see the
answers for the poll very interesting so
fortunately and I'm glad to see that
really no one on the line thinks that
prostate cancers an old man's disease
and no one should be screened I think
that certainly I'm pleased to see that
41.7 percent of the audience thinks that
pretty much all men should have a PSA
test and I would tend to agree with that
I personally believe that a baseline PSA
at about age 40 or 45 is really useful
to determine the man's future risk of
prostate cancer twelve percent of the
audience thinks that just men with
high-risk features should be screened
and then 45.8 think that men between 55
and 69 should be tested generally and
answer number four is the guide line
from the American Urological CA shin so
let's let's move on then and you see a
headline here that
talks about the US Preventive Services
Task Force that's a government agency
that gave PSA testing a derating a
couple of years ago and this headline
from the Journal of the American Medical
Association basically says that this
agency set finds little evidence to
support advising PSA screening in any
man and why did this agency come to this
conclusion we certainly know that the
effectiveness of prostate cancer
screening many questions remain and what
let's go over that just a little bit
well the reason the US Preventive
Services Task Force came to that
conclusion was primarily because the two
major prostate cancer PSA randomized
trials found conflicting results one
trial found that the rates of or the
death rates from prostate cancer did not
differ significantly between men who
were randomized to screening versus
randomized to just routine care without
PSA and the other trial done in Europe
basically found that the death rate for
prostate cancer was reduced twenty
percent in the men who were randomized
to PSA screening so we have these two
conflicting studies looking at it a
little bit further the American study
was called PL CEO that stands for
prostate lung colorectal and ovarian and
they found no mortality benefit for men
who got a PSA test so because it was an
American study and because the US
Preventive Services Task Force is an
American agency basically they said look
you know we kind of go with the PLC oh
no benefit let's not recommend PSA
testing now the PLC Oh study enrolled
seventy six thousand men the European
study that showed a benefit to PSA
testing and roll 182,000 then the
American study used a PSA cut point or
threshold of 4.0 to recommend a prostate
biopsy where is the Europe
he instead he used a threshold of PSA of
three fifty percent of the men who had a
positive screen were biopsied in the
American study so about half of the men
who actually had an abnormal PSA
actually went through with the prostate
biopsy and on the other hand eighty-five
percent of the European men who had an
abnormal screening PSA had biopsy the
biggest challenge of the American study
was PSA contamination and fifty-two
percent versus only twenty percent in
the European study now I'm going to talk
a little bit further about PSA
contamination the definition of PSA
contamination is PSA testing performed
in the control group during or before
entering the trial and this was common
PSA was tested frequently in the control
group in the American study forty
percent of men in the first year who
were randomized to know PSA testing had
a PSA test outside the study and over
the six years of a study more than half
of the men actually had a PSA outside of
the study and forty-four percent of men
in each group had undergone prior PSA
testing prior to entering the study and
so right off the bat that's a huge issue
when you're trying to show that PSA made
a difference if there was a huge
contamination control group and many
experts believe that that was a fatal
flaw on the plc oh and the US Preventive
Services Task Force should have taken
that into more consideration when they
went against the PSA test so again this
this heavily contaminated group who had
testing on PSA outside the study
boundaries now the american urological
association I'm a urologist and I'm a
member of the american urological
association and i tend to
agree with the guidelines that are from
my own professional organization now
granted there are other guidelines on
PSA testing and not all of them agree we
certainly don't have time to go through
all the different guidelines but let's
just talk a little bit about the PSA
guidelines that were released about a
year ago the AUA looked at age groups
they felt that it's important to
recognize that we probably need to look
at this issue differently so they looked
at men less than 40 42 54 55 to 69 and
70 plus to ask the question should we
use PSA testing so I'll just give the
overall highlights in men less than 40
the panel generally recommends against
PSA testing against routine PSA testing
because the prevalence of prostate
cancer is so low below age 40 and so the
feeling was that you probably they do
potentially more harm than benefit in
men under 40 and I generally agree with
that that we really have no business
Glee PSA testing under age 44 the vast
vast vast majority of patients now what
about between 40 and 50 for here the
american urological association
generally is against routine screening
for prostate cancer now in men who have
risk factors such as a family history of
prostate cancer or those men who are
african-american ethnicity there may be
rationale for doing PSA testing and some
experts including myself generally think
that obtaining one baseline PSA value at
about age 40 to 45 is beneficial to help
determine the patient's future risk of
prostate cancer but if we follow the aua
guidelines in general we should not
offer routine PSA testing to average
risk men between 40
54 now for men younger than age 55 who
are higher than average risk such as
again family history such as
african-american ethnicity such as men
who may have had a baseline PSA at 40
that was a little bit higher than what
we would expect those men fall into a
higher risk room and I think you need to
take an individualized approach and
perhaps offer PSA testing selectively
the group that the aea feels is most
likely to benefit from PSA screening is
the age group 55 and 60 to 69 and in
this category of age 55 to 69 the aua
generally is in favor of PSA testing
although we strongly feel that the
patient should have shared
decision-making where the doctor and
healthcare professionals talk about the
pros and cons of PSA testing but to
generally offer the test after a patient
has been informed of the risk versus the
benefit above age 70 the American
neurologic Association generally
recommends against routine routine PSA
testing although we also think we should
take an individualized stands there
certainly are individuals at 70 Plus who
have a long life expectancy and there it
may be appropriate to continue periodic
testing and men older than 70 in
selected situations now let me switch
gears and talk a little bit about
prostate cancer medications that might
affect PSA you see this headline the
drug drugs ability to decrease prostate
cancer risk is confirmed there are a
number of medications that are important
that we at least talk a little bit about
one is finasteride finasteride is a drug
that's been FDA approved for many years
and it's now available as a generic
medication that is FDA approved to treat
benign prostatic hyperplasia
Asia it also causes generally a fifty
percent reduction in PSA levels and we
know that men who are on long-term
finasteride have a 25-percent decreased
risk of developing prostate cancer
although finasteride is not officially
empty approved for chemoprevention
recently long-term safety data has been
released on finasteride showing that it
does not cause lethal high-grade
prostate cancer there was some early
concern that finasteride might lead to
high-grade prostate cancer but long-term
follow-up confirms that there was no
excess death rates in men who were
treated with vaness tried for many years
so I believe finasteride is a very safe
drug I want to mention the Select trial
which was a National Cancer Institute
large trial and the key teaching point
is that vitamin E and selenium do not
prevent prostate cancer furthermore
vitamin E and even perhaps selenium
supplementation actually might increase
the risk of prostate cancer slightly so
the key teaching point i would not
prescribed by the mini or selenium to
try to prevent prostate cancer
dutasteride is also an fda-approved
agent to treat benign prostatic
hyperplasia in the same classes
finasteride and similarly the reduced
trial showed a twenty three percent
reduction in prostate cancer with no
increased risk of high-grade cancer and
this drug also will decrease PSA by
about fifty percent so in practice it's
important for all physicians and
healthcare providers to have a little
working knowledge of finasteride select
trial and dutasteride and this is what i
alluded to earlier on finasteride no
difference in long-term survival with
finasteride or placebo and prostate
cancer prevention trial basically
proving that finasteride is safe with
very long term follow-up
now let me switch gears to localized
prostate cancer and we'll spend a little
time on this topic and basically this is
a gentleman who is diagnosed with
prostate cancer but we believe that the
cancer is clinically contained inside
the prostate so the patient becomes
eligible for localized treatment surgery
radiation therapy cryotherapy and let's
so let's spend a little bit of time with
that let's do an audience polling
question and I want you to answer the
true statement and I'll read them
patients with Gleason 7 our best
candidates for active surveillance is
that true or false for men less than 65
years old middle grade patients such as
Gleason 7 randomized to radical
prostatectomy and improved long-term
survival versus watchful waiting
randomized number 3 randomized trials
have proven that external radiation is
equivalent to radical prostatectomy and
for molecular diagnostic risk assessment
of prostate biopsy tissue has proven
benefit in prospective randomized trials
which one of those statements is true
while we're waiting for the answers I
just want to mention the Gleason 7 would
be considered middle grade prostate
cancer this is middle grade or
intermediate grade prostate cancer
Gleason 6 would be low grade Gleason 7
would be intermediate grade and glisan
eight nine or ten are high grade
prostate cancer so that might help you
answering that question so let's go
ahead and see what our answers are see
if we give enough time so the poll is
closed so the correct
answer is actually be four men less than
65 years old middle grade patients
randomized to radical prostatectomy had
improved long-term survival versus
watchful waiting so that was the correct
answer a lot of the majority of the
audience answer d now I'm going to talk
about molecular diagnostics and I'm a
big fan of using molecular diagnostics
and there have been some excellent
trials done however there have been no
formal prospective randomized trials
done not necessarily that we need those
but I guess maybe this was a trick
question there have been no prospective
randomized trials formally in that
setting showing of molecular diagnostics
for a prostate biopsy tissue that is
proven beneficial but we'll talk about
all four of these now let's move on to
the next slide close our polling there
let's say a few words about active
surveillance so what is active
surveillance active surveillance is
taking a gentleman who has low-grade
generally low grade low stage prostate
cancer and not actively treating him not
doing surgery not doing radiation but
simply following him seeing him back
periodically for repeat lab testing
physical exams such as a rectal exam and
perhaps molecular testing two and only
treating him should his cancer progress
the National Comprehensive Cancer
Network in 2012 basically proclaimed
that active surveillance should be the
only treatment option for very low risk
men who have and men with low-risk
prostate cancer who have an estimated
ten less than ten year life expectancy
and i will say that active surveillance
is growing in popularity
now the a really awesome paper was just
published by Lori clots and colleagues
from Toronto dr. clots and their team in
Toronto I think have the longest running
series of active surveillance and
they've recently published and follow-up
and it's quite interesting so it's
called long-term follow-up of a large
active surveillance cohort of patients
with prostate cancer and I'll just give
you the executive summary the 10 and 15
year actuarial prostate cancer-specific
survival was 98.1 and 94.3 percent so
the wrong term survival of these
patients was excellent at 5 10 15 and 20
years 7563 55 and fifty-five percent of
patients remained untreated on active
surveillance so I think these are good
numbers to counsel patients as to what
their likelihood of remaining on active
surveillance based on the Toronto series
metastatic prostate cancer developed in
two point eight percent of men at a
medium time of almost 10 years after
diagnosis and one point five percent of
men died of prostate cancer of the 28
men developing metastasis forty four
percent were Gleason 7 so what this
tells us is that the middle grade
cancers of Gleason 7 are they seem to be
the ones that are potentially at risk of
developing metastasis and dying of
prostate cancer and kind of tells me
that gosh we really need to pause and
think especially if it's a younger man
in good health before we offer or
routinely do active surveillance on the
majority of men who have Gleason 7
middle grade cancer especially if it's
higher thorium cancer the overall
survival rates were 80% of 10 years and
sixty-two percent at 15 years telling us
that again selecting perhaps older man
and men with low-grade prostate cancer
who have
a significant chance of dying of other
causes before their prostate cancer
progresses make sense and the ratio of
deaths from non prostate cancer to
prostate cancer was nine to 2.1 so in
other words in a properly selected group
of men older men with low-risk low-grade
prostate cancer most of the men are
going to die up other causes and not
prostate cancer and then this ratio is 9
to 2.1 what are some of what are the
reasons for intervention in other words
when do you switch gears you got a guy
on active surveillance and you're
following him when is it time to change
course well in the clock study they used
a PSA doubling time of less than three
years they also used MRI later on in the
series and that's growing in popularity
although it remains controversial
intervention occurred in forty five
point five percent of men due to short
PSA doubling time so basically almost
half the man switched gears from active
surveillance to active treatment because
of their PSA going up at a fairly robust
rate p it short p as they double in time
three increase in histologic grade on
subsequent biopsy led the treatment in
about a third of the patients so again
these gentlemen typically have repeat
biopsies every one two three or four
years depending on the age and healthy
individual and a third of the times that
treatment was they moved from active
surveillance to active treatment was
because of biopsy gleason change or
grade change for clinical progression
such as developing a palpable nodule on
the digital rectal exam confirmed as
cancer was also an indicator of
treatment but we don't know exactly
can't tell exactly how often that
occurred but urologist typically will do
or should do a rectal exam on their
follow-up visits with active
surveillance patients and if you feel a
nodule or feel a change you probably
repeat the biopsy or move on to
treatment especially if there's a
younger healthier man
and patient preference so sometimes
patients just get tired of active
surveillance and that occurred in six
percent so it's a very important study
on active surveillance let's switch
gears and talk about surgery versus
watchful waiting and in March of 2014 a
long-term follow-up of the bill axelsson
Scandinavian trial came out in fact this
was the third published update with 23
years of follow-up I mean long long-term
follow-up at a group of men from
Scandinavia who years ago were
randomized to surgical removal of
prostate versus watchful waiting and now
that we have this incredible long
follower we've learned a lot from this
study this just shows the blue being
death from prostate cancer in all
patients with the left side of the
screen of showing let me just go show
this here this is the left side of the
screen and what you can see here is this
is in all patients who underwent radical
prostatectomy the blue is death from
prostate cancer and if we look at this
this other side this is watchful waiting
and again you can see that the blue here
the death from prostate cancer was
higher for all patients now if we look
at men less than age 75 we see here the
radical prostatectomy patients versus
the watchful waiting patients we look
here at the deaths in blue and we look
at the best in blue so much more
pronounced in men less than age 65
showing a benefit in favor of surgery
again this was the correct answer on the
audience response question a little bit
earlier so again key teaching point for
younger men speaking of key teaching
points that these are some of the
overall key points from this particular
study
over eighty five percent of patients in
this trial had palpable disease in other
words this study was done prior to the
advent of PSA so most of these cancers
were diagnosed based on a positive
digital digital rectal exam so it was a
pre PSA era enrolled study radical
prostatectomy was superior to watchful
waiting for intermediate risk prostate
cancer for most men healthy young men
less than 65 even with low risk
especially if the cancer was palpable
they could feel a nodule should consider
surgery or active treatment but it's
still unclear if and how to use this
information for men with low volume non
palpable Gleason 6 lows PSA prostate
cancer in other words this really
doesn't necessarily say that surgery is
better than modern era active
surveillance that was practiced in the
clots trial but what I would say and
what my tape as a as a clinician is
younger men less than 65 we're on active
surveillance should probably move on to
surgery or active treatment if they
develop a palpable progressive lower
intermediate response tickets remaining
it's a young guy on active surveillance
and he develops a nodule on his prostate
where you and you biopsy it and that is
confirmed this prostate cancer that's
comparable disease he's still young if
you thought believe this bill axelsson
paper probably time for him to move on
to active treatment not everyone agrees
with that but again that was my
practical take-home message let me
switch gears again and talk just a
little bit about genetic tests and
prostate cancer or molecular markers on
you see the headline to new genetic
tests offer personalized medicine for
newly diagnosed prostate cancer this is
a picture my good friend Peter Carroll
from University of California San
Francisco who's been a leader in this
area and let's just show you a little
bit of the waterfront on these molecular
markers and this slide just shows a menu
of summer
things that are commercial are available
prostate health index is a blood test
offered by Beckman Coulter that is FDA
approved it's a similar to PSA it's a
secondary screening blood test that
would give more information than a PSA
test the 4k score is another blood test
offered by up co.labs also provides more
granular information than PSA and may
help and decision-making pca3 as a
molecular urine test done after a
prostate massage where the gentleman
gives a urine sample directly after the
urologist as a prostate massage also
useful as a secondary test is FDA
approved to be used after a negative
biopsy on a man who still has an
elevated PSA you can use pca3 again
after a negative biopsy confirm mdx is a
tissue marker based on methylation that
can be done on a negative prostate
biopsy to give the urologist an
indication if he had missed important
cancer on the biopsy this is a busy
slide that shows compares the PI blood
test to the 48 score to the prosthetics
versus pca3 I just boxed one aspect of
the 4k score that this blood test can
help predict the probability of
intermediate or higher grade prostate
cancer and so even though these tests
are still somewhat in their infancy and
just starting to be employed in
practices this is one blood test that
could be used in the future to help
guide decisions regarding active
treatment versus active surveillance if
you had a excuse me an elevated 4k score
suggesting a reasonable risk of higher
grade cancer yet the biopsy only showed
Gleason 6 this could be a subtle
indicator to rebuy up so you'll move on
active treatment and then after a
negative biopsy again pca3 is the
molecular urine test which is FDA
approved in this setting again a urine
test done after a prostate massage
you're in collected after the digital
rectal exam confirm mdx is done on the
biopsy tissue looking at methylation
changes and gives an indication whether
important cancer may still be lurking in
the prostate that may have been missed
on the initial biopsy and then once a
gentleman has had a positive biopsy for
cancer once you know that there is
prostate cancer and you're trying to
make a decision between active treatment
and active surveillance the two most
common commercially available tissue
markers are the Polaris test off of
binary incorporation and the Oncotype DX
test offered by genomic health we also
use the decipher test and Polaris that
can be done on tissue after a radical
prostatectomy and I on this one slide
I'm just going to briefly provide a
comparison between myriad pro lares and
genomic health GPS both of these are
performed on archival paraffin-embedded
tissue from a prostate biopsy and
measure RNA expression profiles in that
archival prostate cancer tissue the
myriad pro lares focuses on cell cycle
progression genes 31 genes in the active
group and 15 housekeeper genes it
provides a risk score and the test
primarily predicts prostate cancer
disease specific survival and PSA
recurrence or biochemical recurrence it
can be done on biopsy tissue
it's also commercially available for
radical prostatectomy tissue and as of
recently in 2015 does have a
reimbursement coverage for Medicare
patients the genomic health GPS is also
an RNA expression panel of multiple
cellular pathways it has 12 active genes
and five housekeeper genes there's also
a risk score which is zero to 100 on the
genomic health test is used only on
biopsy tissue and it's only approved for
use on glisan sixes and low volume
Gleason three plus four equals seven it
predicts adverse pathology in other
words it gives you a probability if that
patient undergoes radical prostatectomy
what the likelihood is of that patient
having higher grade cancer or higher
stage cancer and both of these and also
has Medicare coverage as a 2015 both of
these tests are designed to help doctors
and patients make better decisions as
whether they're going to do active
surveillance or active treatment both
tests have a fairly robust literature a
lot of literature out on both tests it's
been published on but the answer the
question neither of these tests have
been truly validated in a prospective
randomized control trial yet so they do
have Medicare coverage they're becoming
more widely accepted we'd still like to
see some more prospective data and
longer-term follow-up obviously on both
of them I want to spend just one slide
on one or two slides on prostate MRI
growing in popularity and the key
teaching point is over the last several
years the MRI imaging technology has
improved to the point where many experts
believe that MRI can help better at
NFI prostate tumors inside the prostate
but there are still limitations the MRIs
does not see all tumors MRI increases
the likelihood of finding a Gleason 7 or
intermediate risk to none but really
still can't tell you if that tumor needs
to be treated and MRI has no long-term
follow-up data in the active
surveillance population so we really are
still struggling and learning how and
when to use MRI in a patient that we
have on active surveillance as far as
prostate biopsy whether it's the first
biopsy or the substance a subsequent
biopsy in 2015 they're really two ways
that urologist will do prostate biopsy
the transrectal ultrasound guided
prostate biopsy or trust biopsy or the
MRI directed biopsy the trust biopsy has
the advantage of being widely available
it's efficient a single visit it
actually detects more cancers than MRI
but it's been criticized for over
detection of Gleason 6 low grade cancers
especially those that might be picked up
in older or elderly individuals and the
ultrasound is felt to be more random
than ultrasound and because the
ultrasound cannot necessarily see these
tumors nevertheless it's the remains the
gold standard with regard to insurance
reimbursement and efficiency the MRI
directed biopsy is not yet widely
available it generally would require a
separate visit for the MRI test and then
the MRI has to be processed and then it
would require a second visit for the
transrectal ultrasound because what
happens
is the software is able to fuse or
overlay the findings from the MRI on the
transrectal ultrasound and so what's
happening is the urologist is using the
information from the MRI to better guide
his trust biopsy the second visit though
for the trust the trust generally takes
more time because of the technology
involved although the time is getting a
little bit better and it's important for
patients and doctors to recognize that
this detects fewer cancers but you're
supposedly selectively picking up only
Gleason 7 or important cancers so
patients have to be aware that the MRI
may actually do less good a job of
picking up all cancers but it may only
pick up the important cancers and I will
just say stay tuned this is an emerging
area and I just was able to cover
scratch the surface the last thing that
we're going to cover today briefly is
advanced prostate cancer this would be
metastatic generally metastatic prostate
cancer or even men who have what they
call castrate-resistant prostate cancer
which is far advanced prostate cancer
after patient has progressed on hormonal
therapy so let's go into our final
audience response question other let's
see we get that up never mind I don't
happy we're going to get to that in a
minute excuse me let me just set the
stage for advanced disease hormonal
therapy which will call HT is also
called androgen deprivation therapy or
ADT and this is the mainstay of
treatment for advanced prostate cancer
and this has been the treatment since
the 1940s in the early 1940s it was
discovered that a man who underwent an
orchiectomy surgical removal of both
testicles responded beautifully and many
times advanced prostate cancer got
better
and then we learned that about the
reason for that was that testosterone
the male sex hormone which is produced
by the testicles was the fuel for
advanced prostate cancer so ever since
the early 1940s hormonal therapy has
been widely used initially as
orchiectomy and then for the last 30
years as medical castration or medical
hormone therapy in the form of of shots
or injections and pills and these shots
are either lhrh agonists such as
leuprolide acetate orga saraland acetate
or gnrh pure antagonist current
commercially available one is dagger
alex you could also still do an
orchiectomy and some doctors would also
add in oral anti-androgen medications
for a better hormonal blockade and
that's called complete hormonal therapy
doctors can use this hormonal therapy
intermittently meaning you basically get
patient shots off and on or continues
where you just continue the hormone
treatment for the rest of the patients
right for EM 1 which is metastatic
prostate cancer mostly a patient would
have a positive bone scan or a cat scan
showing distant metastases continuous
hormone therapy is probably a little
more effective and one now over the last
couple years you're really trying to
maintain a low testosterone level less
than 20 but we also know that hormone
therapy RN church and deprivation
therapy has toxicity increase in the
risk of diabetes and potentially
increasing the risk of cardiac disease
and so it's a double-edged sword some
patients with metastatic disease clearly
have a better benefit for long-term use
but some other patients with less
advanced disease we're going to try to
use the hormonal therapy intermittently
to avoid side effects and then in far
advanced castrate resistant disease
there are several new novel oral
hormonal therapies that are fda-approved
so with that background let me just
spend a couple of slides here is an
example of a randomized trial again done
by dr. klotzenstein tagging is dagger
Alex on a monthly basis versus the lhrh
agonists leuprolide acetate and what
they found is the biggest difference is
in the first month we're with the lhrh
agonists you see a flare phenomenon
where the testosterone surges and then
eventually gets down to very low levels
by about a month versus dagger alex
where you get an immediate quick
blockade and at about ninety percent of
patients 90 some percent of patients or
castrate testosterone level by day three
so the key teaching point is if you have
a patient with advanced prostate cancer
where you're really trying to get quick
action generally deger alex has become
very popular as the drug to start with
because of this early quick mechanism of
action and then some sometime later on
the patient would switch to an lhrh
antagonist such as leuprolide acetate
this slide just talks about some of the
side effects of androgen deprivation
therapy in the cardiovascular risk we
know that long-term hormonal therapy
increases the risk of obesity has an
effect on serum lipids increases insulin
or decreases insulin sensitivity can
increase blood pressure increase waist
hip ratio and has some effect on
c-reactive protein it's a growing
recognition that especially in younger
healthier patients we really want to
balance the risk and benefits of
hormonal therapy use and it's still
somewhat controversial regarding
cardiovascular disease whether the
androgen deprivation therapy really does
increase the risk of cardiovascular
disease but again the key teaching point
there are a lot of side effects of
hormonal therapy so you really we really
want to balance the risk benefit before
we prescribe hormonal therapy now on hot
news chemotherapy and newly diagnosed
advanced prostate cancer this is from
ASCO post docetaxel combined with
hormone therapy extend survival and
advanced prostate cancer and this is i
would say an advanced prostate cancer
this has been the biggest news over the
last year first about a year ago the
Charter trial was released this was
chris sweeney who's a friend of mine
he's a medical oncologist out of the
dana-farber principal investigator on
this study they randomized over 700 men
with new metastatic prostate cancer in
other words these would be a guy say
just walking it off the screen never
been treated for prostate cancer never
been diagnosed and unfortunately had
metastatic disease on initial
presentation randomized to arm a which
was hormone therapy plus six cycles of
docetaxel versus arm b which at the time
was standard of care androgen
deprivation alone and they were followed
for progression and death 790 men were
rolled between 2006 and 2020 and excuse
me 2012 and on january 16 2014 with a
median follow-up of 29 months there 136
deaths in the intrusion deprivation or
malone and 101 deaths in the ATT plus
chemotherapy US attacks on chemotherapy
arm and this is the survival curve could
have quite striking difference so
androgen deprivation therapy for plus
docetaxel six cycles fifty seven point
six months median survival verses 44
months in the hormone therapy alone and
again you can see that here at median
there's a significant difference here in
favor of patients who receive docetaxel
and so this caught I think a lot of
people off guard in the field I think
people were surprised by these results
early on the Charter trial seemed to
suggest that there was a bigger benefit
in patients who had higher extent of
disease so in patients with high-volume
metastatic disease there was a 17-month
improvement in median overall survival
in patients with low volume metastatic
disease there was a fairly robust hazard
ratio in favor of combined therapy but
the survived the p-value was not yes
this statistically significant probably
because there were fewer patients and
who had low volume disease nevertheless
pretty striking results and before I
move on this year at ASCO the Stampede
trial which basically confirmed these
results so we had chartered and then we
had Stampede so at ASCO 2014 we had
charter at ASCO 2015 we had Stampede
with it which is a British trial which
essentially confirmed the chartered
results and I would say right now and
most of our major hospitals around the
world if it's a patient presenting de
novo with new metastatic prostate cancer
we are encouraged to talk to the patient
about androgen deprivation therapy and
encourage those patients who also be
seen by a medical oncologist for
consideration of docetaxel on
chemotherapy the last section here
before we open it up for questions is
FDA approvals 2010 2 2013 for advanced
disease and this these are approvals for
castrate-resistant prostate cancer so
I'm going to just very very briefly
cover syphilis LT or Provenge which
improved 2010 cabassa taxol which is a
chemotherapy approved again in 2010 we
are not going to have time to cover XG
borden ocimum this is a rank ligand
inhibitor given sub-q to prevent
skeletal related events in advanced
prostate cancer a new oral hormonal
therapy abiraterone tradename Zytiga
proved in 2011 and another oral
anti-intrusion and salute amide or
expanding approved in 2012 and then
radium-223 or so figo approved in 2013
so we've really had some major advances
in castrate-resistant prostate cancer
now here's our final audience response
question we can not get the so here's
our poll which of these is the true
statement provenge is a novel
immunotherapy that lowers PSA levels an
average by a factor of 4.5 be cabassa
taxol is a novel radiopharmaceutical
agent that does not cause bone marrow
suppression see abiraterone acetate is
best taken with meals or d denotes
amount 120 milligrams sub-q monthly is
used to prevent skeletal related events
which of those four statements is the
true statement and I will tell you that
you know Provenge or syphilis LT is a
very novel immunotherapy of and we use
it quite a bit at duke composite axial
again another agent that we use quite
frequently in our prostate Center and
obviously our own acetate is one of the
new neural nodes novel oral agents why
don't we go ahead and close the polling
and see how our audience did on this way
so let's see here and the correct answer
is d de no samad so a third of the
audience got this correct soda no some
ass
is given 120 120 milligrams sub-q
monthly useless prevent skeletool and
invent Provenge is a novel immunotherapy
but that it does not lower PSA on
average by a factor of 4.5 cabassa taxol
is a chemotherapy not a
radiopharmaceutical abiraterone is best
taken with on an empty stomach so again
have to lose so the correct answer is d
so just a couple of final slides I know
we're getting down to the wire here as
far as our allotted time but cabeza
taxol is fda-approved in two thousand
key teaching point it is a chemotherapy
FDA approved based on the tropic trial
it's used post docetaxel and resulted in
a survival benefit as you see on this
slide for men with castrate-resistant
prostate cancer who had progressed after
docetaxel cabassa taxol is produced by
sanofi aventis and it's now fairly
widely used in patients with advanced
prostate cancer there are four now for
fda-approved chemotherapy agents and
prostate cancer docetaxel which is now
generic but what trade name was Taxotere
my techs antrone estra musty and
composite axial trade name Jim Tom so
again for fda-approved chemotherapies
for use in advanced prostate cancer sip
tea or Provenge was FDA approved in 2010
basically it's a very novel immune
product it's created individually for a
patient patient undergoes leuco for asus
as you see here then the patient has his
white cells collected these are
processed and then infused back into the
patient it's done three times over about
a month the impact trial which was the
key trial resulting in fda approval
showed about a four point one month
median overall survival benefit of
Provenge I would say the most important
information especially for me as a
neurologist is based on what we call the
quartile beta looking at when patients
received Provenge related to their
baseline PSA and the key teaching point
is in men who had baseline
castrate-resistant prostate cancer but
lower PSAs baseline PSA less than about
20 to the survival benefit was 13 months
so again picking patients properly for
this immunotherapy seems to be critical
immunotherapy tends to work best with
patients with minimal tumor burden and
if PSA is a general surrogate for tumor
burden this would suggest that this
makes sense related to the mechanism of
action of immunotherapy abiraterone the
oral agent is a licen hibbett ER it
works in the steroidal pathway it's
going to block asteroidal conversion
here at the hydroxylase and lies so it's
going to prevent the development of the
hormonal agents along the pathway it
would actually drive hormone drive the
sternal pathway back this direction
towards aldosterone production but the
key teaching point is this form this
blockade and historical pathway lowers
tissue lowers androgens and this could
be from this testicular source the
adrenal source or the tumor itself
source so abiraterone is going to be a
blocker that's going to work at all the
areas in the body to lower androgen
levels quite remarkable efficacy this
shows on time this is in pre
chemotherapy treated patients castrate
resistant patients who have not yet
received chemotherapy showing a
significant Martin remarkable
improvement in radiographic
free survival overall survival benefit
in the latest final overall survival
analysis of all patients with some four
point four months but remember too that
the control arm here went on to receive
other effective treatments after arbor
on our own so you have to always put
that into context of this agent with
four point four months but the control
arm moved on to other treatments mdv
3100 also called enzalutamide also known
as the tradename drug expand d is an
antigen signalling inhibitor it has
efficacy demonstrated pre and post
chemotherapy 160 milligrams orally once
day can be given with or without
prednisone well tolerated agent again
similar to a bladder on a very marked
improvement and radiographic
progression-free survival and a marked
improvement in overall survival in the
updated overall survival analysis so
both of these agents abiraterone and
enzalutamide have added widely to our
armamentarium for advanced prostate
cancer obviously neither of these agents
are necessarily home run agents but the
drugs have clearly made a difference and
and can delay the time to chemotherapy
in some patients by more than two years
so widely used widely effective I wanted
to have at least two or three minutes
for questions again I really want to
thank you very much for paying it for
listening in this morning and tuning in
and let's go on right into the questions
and we can go ahead and just address
these quickly since we do have about two
minutes left ah do you think so let's
there's a question from Jeff Rocio from
Co veras incorporated do you think is it
do you think it is possible that in
older patients with less than 10 year
life expectancy on
radiation and chemotherapy can actually
shorten their lifespan when compared to
active surveillance in other words our
older patients better off skipping
treatment and just enjoying their lives
with no worries great question Jeff
again I think in some cases that's
absolutely true i think if you if you
take it certainly if you take a patient
with low-risk prostate cancer low low
Gleason score low grade disease many of
those patients are going to be ideal
candidates for active surveillance on
the other hand you know even if you have
an older patient with high-grade
metastatic prostate cancer there's no
question that hormonal therapy can have
a dramatic palliative benefit as far as
bone pain these new agents such as
abiraterone and enzalutamide can clearly
improve quality of life and delay
chemotherapy for up to two years so
again I think the key teaching point is
taking an individualized approach
question here from Diego quinone asst
from central university according
according to Harvard Medical School
study frequent ejaculation help ward off
prostate cancer what do you think and I
think it sounds like a lot of fun and no
seriously I think there have been
studies suggesting that more frequent
ejaculation especially for men between
you know teenage years in the 40s may
showed a decreased risk of future
prostate cancer certainly would make
sense but I think again we're just about
at a time I'm going to turn the podium
over to our moderator
thank you dr. Mel just a reminder if you
wish to obtain the credits for today's
session please click on the get your
free cm ECE credits button located in
the lower left of your screen and follow
the instructions this will take you to
the continuing education page where you
can select a speaker click on the CEC
Emmy button and be guided through the
process to obtain your certification
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through March 30 of
2016 you will receive an email from lab
roots alerting me when this webcast will
be available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcements your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye